[Music]
a florida mother is demanding justice
after disturbing video showed
a state trooper tasing her 16 year old
son
surveillance video captured the trooper
tasing jack rodeman in his girlfriend's
backyard
last week the mother said he had
permission to be there
she told art manuel baharkis that she
believes her son
who is biracial was racially profiled
i didn't do nothing i told you to do
something home security footage shows 16
year old jack rhodeman standing on the
back porch of his girlfriend's home last
week
when he came face to face with a state
trooper pointing a taser at him
seconds later the trooper fires the
taser and wrote him in slams into the
ground
his girlfriend is traumatized the mom's
traumatized i'm traumatized
christina rodeman says her son
desperately tried to text his girlfriend
to come outside
she says he didn't pose a threat and
believes instead race played a role
i think he was totally profiled that cop
turned around and followed him back
that direction when you say profiled
what do you mean it's a black kid in
black clothes
by the time rodeman's girlfriend came
out of the house moments later the
trooper was already placing the teen in
handcuffs
according to the arrest report the
trooper said he followed rodeman into
the backyard because he looked
suspicious
and that when the teen saw the patrol
car he darted and hid in the bushes
he added that the boy's behavior
appeared to be a burglar
put your hands behind him i'm going to
do it again the trooper said he was
forced to tase rodeman when he
didn't follow commands to put his hands
behind his back
some people would ask if he complied
then it wouldn't have escalated probably
and i agree he should have dropped his
phone
he's a good kid but he is defiant with
the law enforcement a little bit
you just don't take out a taser and
shoot somebody and there's no
active resistance former police officer
dave thomas
now trains other officers on use of
force and calls the troopers actions
egregious
my question is what does a burglar look
like there's nothing that distinguishes
that other than being a black kid
in black clothing that's it
rodeman is being held at a juvenile
detention center where he's facing
multiple charges including resisting
arrest
and possession of marijuana he was on
probation his mother says for stealing a
golf cart with a friend
last year the florida highway patrol
says the incident involving the trooper
who was named investigator of the year
last march remains under review tony
all right manny thank you very much
anthony i think you
you say well what's the definition of
suspicion yeah i mean when someone says
he looks suspicious i don't know what
that means
i know pretty wide open